The first thing I want to talk about in material optimizations is this concept of parent materials.
Now, parent material workflow is not an optimization for performance, but it is a workflow optimization,
as setting your materials up in this manner will allow your team members to work faster,
and also allow you to make massive sweeping changes to the materials in your project with a few clicks of a button.
Material instances work using a parent-child relationship.
So, on the left-hand side of the screen, we have a biological parent setup.
In this very simplified setup of biology, we have parents that pass traits on down to their children.
So, these two parents come together, and out of the red, green, or blue boxes that they have available,
their children will be a red, green, or blue box.
And the reason I'm bringing this up is that, again, in biology, we have parents that have traits that are passed on down to their children,
and their children will select one of those traits, and that's what they'll be presented with.
And this is how our parent material system can work.
Next to this parent-children example, we have two parent materials, a matte ENV building parent and a matte ENV glass parent.
Taking a look at the matte ENV building parent, to the right of it, we have some material instances.
Notice that the first instance, brick 01, looks almost identical to our matte ENV building parent.
The next to that brick 01, we have brick 02. This looks almost identical, but it's a completely different color.
Finally, we have our rock 01 instance, and this looks nothing like either brick 01, brick 02, or even the base parent.
And this really signifies the power of this system.
This means that we can have parent materials that can control massive amounts of props inside of our project,
and when we work inside of them, we can make these changes and have all of those changes propagated down to the children.
Now underneath that, I have this matte ENV glass parent, and notice there's three different ones of those.
Now, the variation inside of these is not as extreme as the above example,
but the reason we have two different versions is because when you're making parent materials,
making one monolithic or massive parent material will not help your project,
and is actually a very inefficient way to work with materials inside of Unreal Engine.
This is because when we build one massive monolithic parent material to try and meet every single need of our materials,
we are going to generate a lot of extra permutations of that material.
Remember, when we're building materials using our material graph, what we are doing is we're actually using a visual interface to write our material.
We are not going to be doing this in one draw call, so if we put everything inside of one material that's not going to allow us to save any instructions,
that is going to just make that one massive shader extremely inefficient, and also generate a ton of shader permutations,
which is going to blow out our shader cache file, causing long compile times.
What's a better way to approach this is to separate your parent materials into different categories.
For example, if we have environment, we have an environment parent material.
If we have special effects, we have one for that.
If we need one for glass, we have one for glass, and so on.
This way we have a very versatile material, but one that is not set up to meet every need,
but to meet many needs of a select group of assets.
There is no limit on the amount of parent materials you can have, or material instances,
but you should take some time to consider how you're going to set things up,
so that when you are utilizing parent materials and material instances in your project,
artists and designers will understand which materials they should be using to base their work off of.